Alrighty everybody, it is time for "Drew's News."
The only news with an ulcer free guarantee.
And with me at the desk is my human Tum Tum Tum Tums,
Rossi Ross Mathews.
Hi Tum Tum, hi everybody.
(crowd cheering)
You are human medicine.
Thank you.
I love you so much.
I love you Drew.
How's your day going?
So far so good, how about you?
I got really weird, bad news and then really good news.
And I was like, that's so life.
Oh God, right?
Like the aahaa.
Balance, yeah.
You know, that's how my morning's been.
Yeah, good, so we're good, right?
Yeah, we're great.
Alright, great, bring it on.
Well, speaking of aahaa, Harry Styles is set to
hit the Coachella Stage again next weekend,
because he already nailed it this past weekend.
"Marie Claire" reports that Harry brought out a surprise
guest pop icon, Shania Twain.
And they both dressed up in head to toe sequence.
They sang, "Man, I feel like a Woman",
which is a great title, 'cause it includes everybody.
And Harry revealed that he listened to so much Shania
with his mom in the car growing up.
He says that Shania taught him how to sing,
gave him amazing memories with his mom,
and also taught him men are trash.
Harry's album coming out called "Harry's House"
is about to drop.
But his first single has already broken records
as it got 16 million streams
in its first 24 hours on Spotify.
(crowd cheering)
I think I was responsible for like a million of those.
I love Harry Styles, he's so talented.
And then he brings out Shania Twain.
Well that do impress me much, thank you so much.
I love Shania Twain and you know, Coachella,
have you guys ever been to Coachella, me either.
It sounds like so much...
I live in Palm Springs when I'm not here in New York.
That's right, you're so adjacent.
Totally, and you can hear
the thump thump thump of it going on.
And meanwhile, I'm pouring a Pinot Grigio on ice
by the pool, because it is too much for me.
But Harry Styles might just bring me out.
I love how I said Harry Styles might bring me out.
Well, honey, I'm already out, but you know what I mean.
You are out.
You know what I mean.
If anyone could do it again.
(upbeat music)